researchers are working hard to
determine the cause of more than 500
cases of lung illness affecting East
cigarette users eight of those people
have died but even before this outbreak
East cigarettes had divided the medical
community the American Lung Association
says bluntly a cigarette Tsar not safe
but the American Cancer Society and the
other hand says they are quote
significantly less harmful for adults
than smoking regular cigarettes another
complication the latest figures showed
nearly 5 million children use
e-cigarettes we wanted to see the
science for ourselves one of the web's
most talked about Pro vaping videos is
an experiment comparing the effects of
tobacco cigarettes and e-cigarettes on
the lungs here is the Belgium cigarette
smoke I mean it just is so revolting put
out by none other than England's top
public health agency my research shows
that he cigars are significantly less
harmful than cigarettes public health
England describes ecig arrests as at
least 95 percent less harmful than
tobacco cigarettes but is that really
true
I would agree with that and actually I
would go further I think there's now
evidence from looking at the cancer
biomarkers that it could be as high as
98 or 99 percent for cancers David
Abrams is a professor at New York
University we asked his colleagues in
the School of Medicine to recreate the
experiment by public health England this
is gonna look very yucky you're gonna
see lots of brown and dark color and
that's what's gonna simulate what goes
in the lungs of people let's see what
happens
for about two hours the NYU team
simulated smoking four packs of
cigarettes comparing it to the same
amount of vaping in the end oh the aroma
do you smell that the differences were
plain to see
so this right here this is tar yes the
damage caused by cigarette smoke was
obvious look at that this is only four
packs of cigarettes so this much
material it might not all deposit the
long of a smoker but this must material
is entering their mouth and entering the
lungs she's nasty
oh the vapor from a coffee flavored eat
liquid not so much there's a little
dampness smells like coffee yes
public health England is saying 95
percent less harmful you think that is
true or not I think that's a fairly
accurate statement maybe eighty ninety I
don't know how they can be that accurate
that I said yes it's they're much safer
than cigarettes but other American
scientists like mark Alford are drawing
very different conclusions I would say
it's 95 percent harmful because in any
single study that I've seen that's
looking at this in a meaningful way
outside the lung they're finding damage
and harm inside this lab at West
Virginia University Alford investigates
the potential long-term effects of
vaping not on the lungs but on the heart
his team is exposing rodents to
e-cigarette vapor
in a recent study he looked at eight
months of exposure the equivalent of 25
human years and what he found concerns
him
the machine is detecting a higher
velocity of flow through these vessels
the animals arteries stiffened almost as
much as those exposed to cigarette smoke
over the same time and stiffer arteries
means greater risk for stroke for heart
attack alpha sclerosis aneurysms any
number of vascular effects it's alarming
to find this it's extremely alarming
because it tells me that each cigarettes
simply are not going to be safer than
cigarettes he's now trying to figure out
why it happens he says it's not the
nicotine it's something in the base
solution the base solution is made up of
propylene glycol and vegetable glycerin
these are oils petroleum yeah the
advocates of e-cigarettes say look it's
just a little oil and water vapor that's
it well so that's that's actually the
biggest lie about e-cigarettes is that
its water vapor that's that's an oil and
petroleum solution when you think about
the so called continuum of risk you know
you've got pure air over here healthiest
thing on the planet and you've got
cigarettes over here one of the most
deadly things ever invented where is an
e-cigarette on that scale I think it's
just about as far as close to cigarettes
as you can possibly get and the CDC is
now advising people worried about health
risks to avoid vaping but at the same
time they say anyone using e-cigarettes
to quit smoking should not go back to
cigarettes may 20 24 a cigarette
manufacturers to demonstrate that they
are a net good for public health you go
to CBS this morning calm to see more of
our conversation with dr. David Abrams
from NYU and he's gonna talk about why
he's certain that e-cigarettes are a
benefit for public health but as he saw
from Mark Alford portion of the story he
says look the lung problem may be less
with e-cigarettes but you got to look at
the whole body system and the arteries
are a different story he's suggesting
that NYU is looking in only one place
exactly yeah this is I mean it's where
you see scientists you know conflicting
like yeah indeed indeed and one clear
takeaway though I think is it's
important that the CDC is now saying if
you were a smoker who went
cigarettes they're willing to say don't
go back no maybe not stay but don't go
back this reminds me of that debate
about ten years ago between corn syrup
and sugar which is better for you yeah
that's just they're both bad the totally
one of these two-part camps is correct
and we have millions of lives at stake
all right they report to any thanks